so over the weekend i got together
um with a friend of mine who hosts
another show
like this one i don't want to say who it
is because you know they
they may not want their their view to be
particularly public but one of the
things we talked about
is how lately we are hearing these
defenses of authoritarians from the
people on the right that we would expect
to hear them from
but the contingent of the left which
we used to call the authoritarian left
and i guess we still do
but it used to be way smaller the
portion of the left
that is sort of playing coy with and
often defending
authoritarian strongman types
is growing to the point that it is a
really
major concern i think for those who um
are really on the uh sort of libertarian
progressive left and that small
libertarian as in not authoritarian not
i'm not talking rand paul libertarianism
i'm talking
between on the authoritarian libertarian
scale
you're on the libertarian uh progressive
left
and uh there's now increasingly sort of
a rift within the left and one of the
things i spoke about with my my friend
and fellow host was
that sometimes it occurs to us that
it would be really great to do some kind
of an expose
about like what why are we seeing
uh this linkage this cozy relationship
between the right authoritarian sort of
populist rhetoric people
and some on the left who seem to support
the exact same
authoritarians and this sometimes is
assad
uh sometimes it's nicholas maduro
sometimes it's putin
sometimes it's playing koi with china uh
and
there are certainly other examples and
fundamentally what i think this is about
and if
if you want examples of this just look
at a tucker carlson program
one or two nights a week and see who
tucker is having on from the supposed
left
where they find common ground and we're
supposed to believe
they are crossing partisan lines in
order to find areas of agreement that
just makes sense
when the reality is that the
authoritarian left has
always had plenty in common with the
right it's not that they're escaping
partisan is partisanship
to come together where it makes obvious
sense on uncontroversial issues
it's actually that the authoritarian
aspect of some on the left
really is not very left it's really
quite right wing that that's the reality
of what's going on
and along these lines fox news
ran a bizarre glowing profile of
vladimir putin
in ahead of joe biden's meeting with
putin
and fundamentally what this is about for
both the right
and the left is that for different
reasons they want to delegitimize
the idea that somebody
on the left meaning a democrat is going
to
hold such an authoritarian
accountable because for those on the
right
it's about we just never want to allow
any democrat
to appear strong going back to john
kerry and even before
it's about the feminization of democrats
it's about the
these are not strong people these are
sissies etcetera that's that's why fox
news
would want to sort of portray putin as
masculine and and a glowing profile
advance of meeting with biden so that
they don't uh
they could want to make biden look bad
and for the left it's this stuff of
any time the united states even stands
up to anyone that's neoliberalism
that's uh hegemonic that's colonialism
etc and so hey
the the the right and these aspects of
the left
um end up wanting to similarly raise up
people like vladimir putin i will never
get it but let's take a look at some of
this
uh glowing profile it's it's almost
north korea ask in some way
of vladimir putin on fox news and the
overwhelming support you'd have to look
to the man who came before him
and the drunken antics seemed the exact
opposite of vladimir putin
steve harrigan lived in russia for 10
years and he's got more
on this now boris yeltsin vladimir putin
studying contrasts right a sharp
contrast john especially at the very
start when putin came in in 1999
his approval ratings for an unknown were
overwhelmingly high
and part of the reason was just the
physical contrast he made
with boris yeltsin by 1999 most russians
were ready for a change
the hero who stood on the tank in 1991
and broke communist control over freedom
of speech
elections and private property was also
blamed by those
who saw their life savings disappear as
a new class of billionaires
scooped up state factories yeltsin's
lengthy disappearances from public view
were blamed on heart attacks
or excessive drinking to many russians
president boris yeltsin felt like an
embarrassment
he was very famous for so this is all
the build-up to get to the great putin
right this is all about the bad stuff
about yeltsin first
he inibriated he was a non-alcoholic and
a big drinker
he was very large um just a stature
so the way that he behaved in these
high-level
public diplomacy meetings through the
u.s presidents or other heads of state
embarrassed a lot of russians at the
time the physical contrast with
putin was stark and if you're if you're
not watching
they they're running video of putin
lifting weights and then it gets even
more sycophantic
he's a martial arts champion he says he
never drinks
and for many russians that also gave
them a sense of stability
mr putin embodied that physically in a
way
that president yeltsin absolutely did
not
putin also embodied a return to an
authoritarian past
shutting down press freedom banishing
independent oligarchs
and consolidating power in his own hands
putin could be around for a long time to
come he's changed the constitution he
could potentially
be in office until the year 2036
john he knows how to consolidate power
no question about that
steve harrigan for steve thank you so
much and
and can you imagine sandra boris yeltsin
on horseback without a shirt on
not a pretty picture yeah so there it is
and so fundamentally what
what i think is going on here there are
more and more people that are actually
calling out
not just the right but also those on the
left who are playing coy
with these guys um i i think there's a
couple
important things to uh to to sort of
keep in mind here
uh number one is that um there
is no circumstance in which progressive
values
align with the way that vladimir putin
runs
government uh bashar al-assad
nicholas maduro sometimes there will be
people on the left even even defending
hamas it's often the exact same people
um
there there's nothing progressive about
that and it's really important to
to bear that in mind but one of the
really
toxic things that's going on with the
left on this issue
is when someone like me for example
calls this out
i will be called everything from a
zionist even though this doesn't
directly relate
putin doesn't directly relate to the
israeli-palestinian conflict although
some of those people are also playing
pretty koi
with hamas to a neo-liberal
colonialist to a faux progressive
to a right-winger etc etc but
what i would challenge those folks to
look at is
if you look at the history of social
democracy around the world
and in northern europe etc when has
progressive social democracy ever looked
like people
like vladimir putin and assad
and she and maduro etc
and so the case i would make is that
this sort of authoritarian left that
plays
coy with this stuff that fox news does
on putin and others
they are the ones that have been either
led astray or for whatever personal
reasons
have decided that that's the direction
they want to go in
the progressive social democracy
movement looks quite similar today to
what it did decades and decades ago
and unfortunately with a lot of these
examples
if you follow the money you start to
learn a lot about why some of these
factions are staking out the positions
that they're staking out and maybe we'll
say more about that in the future
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge
guessing game for me i didn't know what
i actually needed i didn't know what i
would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a
10-year warranty
you can try the mattress free for 100
nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video